Welcome to [music] Daily with Doc and
Becca. This program is for educational
purposes only. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases. [music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials [music] are shared as
individual experiences of the individual
sharing their testimony. Results vary
and [music] may not be typical. We do
not make any claims regarding health or
income. As an empowered individual,
[music]
you do have options available. We are
honored to have the founding father of
the science of epigenetics guiding us
with the best options to obtain or
maintain optimal health, Dr. Joel
Wallik.
Hello everybody. Welcome to Daily with
Doc and Becca. My name is Becca Dukes
and I am honored to be able to bring to
you information to put in your toolbox
to help you as an individual be more
empowered when it comes to your health
journey. That's what Daily with Doc is
all about is providing information to
you about what we can do as individuals.
So I hope that my audio settings are set
properly. And as we are going through
looking at what it is that we can do as
individuals,
let's keep in mind there's a thing
called epigenetics. Epigenetics is the
dis it's the science
that proves
the theory of disease transmission
to that is said is genetic is incorrect.
So, if you have been told that you have
a genetic condition because other people
in your family and even if other people
in your family don't have this poor
health condition and they're telling you
that it's genetic, chances are that is
absolutely
incorrect.
And I am going to bring to the screen
with me Dr. Joel Wallik who is one of
the founding fathers of the science of
epigenetics. And as you can see, he is
holding up a book. That is him on the
front cover. Can't really see it. You're
just, but he's holding a baby monkey.
And this is part of his research in a
time in his life where he was
discovering diseases that were said to
be genetic and human genetic diseases
that ended up not being so. So, Dr.
Joel, Dr. Wallik is just a pioneer when
it comes to the power of nutrition and
what it can do in our lives. Now,
for those of you who are joining us for
the first time or the second time or the
third time, if somebody shared this
program with you, I hope you sure
remember who that is because that person
thought enough about you, cared enough
about you to share this program with you
because they know deep in their heart
that you're going to find something that
is going to help you on this thing we
call a health journey. Get back with
them. Tell them thank you for taking the
time to share this program with you. And
if you have any questions, they're going
to be your point of contact to get
answers from. If they don't have an
answer, they have resources to help them
find answers. Now, if you found this
program all on your own and you would
like to get in touch with a certified
holistic health coach, you are not on
this journey alone.
We are here to help you as an individual
find what is going to be a best fit for
you based on you as an individual.
So we've been trained by an amazing team
that includes Dr. Wallik on Dr. Wallik's
research, how the four areas of health
are affected by nutritional
deficiencies, which we're going to be
talking specifically about one today,
and solutions.
Folks, we can be
I mean, we're surrounded by a world that
dwells on problems.
Well, we don't just dwell on a problem.
We see a problem, we find a solution.
And these solutions that we are offering
to you through this program are
solutions that are helping thousands and
thousands and thousands and maybe even
hundreds of thousands around the world
each and every day. They're solutions
that are proven. Now, this program is
meant for educational purposes only. It
is not meant to take the place of your
primary care physician, nor are the
products meant to treat, ti, diagnose,
or cure any disease. But folks, we have
a divine creation
within our bodies.
When we take care of this creation, this
temple,
it can do some amazing things when given
the right ingredients.
And that is what I absolutely love about
the programs that we are offering to you
today.
offered and put together by the man who
started this crusade, Dr. Joel Wallik.
Now, Dr. Wallik
started as a young child trying to
figure himself out. He did not want to
be locked up. He he did not want to be
considered a crazy kid. He was looking
around and saw that the animals that he
was in charge of taking care of didn't
have these conditions. So he decided as
a child to take it upon himself to start
eating what they're eating, not what the
others were eating. And lo and behold,
because of what was built in to those
animal pellets or that what he was
feeding his his animals, he was able to
let go of those health conditions that
were that were basically plaguing him.
And that was just the beginning. He went
on to be uh go into to college after
being able to successfully participate
in team sports. Went into college, got a
bachelor of science in plant and soil
medicines, soil sciences rather, sorry.
He um worked his way through college in
the pathology lab where he actually um
was able to do a study on 500 lambs that
had died instantly overnight
and he found the cause and also how to
prevent that. So folks that's just the
beginning of what this amazing doctor
has done. He has three post-doates in
pathology with some major
researches,
expeditions, let's use that word that he
has been sent on um some of them by the
Institute of or sorry the National
Institute of Health
um to to find the causes the preventions
of of things going around the world
including to save the white rhino that
was facing extinction in South Africa.
His conservation work that he did there
and making sure that the nutrients were
within the soils of the areas that they
were grazing so that they had better
yields whenever it came to reproducing.
And that's only a part of it. After
that, he went on and he was working in
the zoos where he found the cause of
liver cancer
in the bears around the zoos. Now,
folks, if it was genetic and you're
looking at bears of different species
that have never even met each other and
never even seen each other, not for
decades and decades and generations and
generations,
how could it be genetic? Well, he proved
that it was not genetic. and many other
things he has proven that are not
genetic which is what has led to the
science of epigenetics.
Now he also did a study on 1700 children
who had died overnight in Kon China
where they had called it Kesan disease.
He found that again it was not genetic
but nutritional deficiencies.
He went on to become a naturopathic
physician and he is here with us after
decades and decades of helping people.
He continues to do so. Dr. Joel Wallik,
welcome to Daily with Doc.
>> Well, thank you Rebecca. Thank you for
the kind introduction and um yeah, it's
uh what should I say it's been so
exciting over the 75 years that I've
been working on this and it's getting
more exciting every minute and um we
have so many things going on.
Um [clears throat]
the tools are coming in like crazy. Um,
one of my favorite tools, of course, is
Dead Doctors Don't Lie, the book. And
there is, most people don't realize it,
but there is a DVD. It's a two hours and
9 minutes long. It's lecture after
lecture after lecture. And on the back,
it talks about 30 different diseases
that I cover in this DVD. Okay? It's
called um make sure I get it correct
here. Um dead doctors don't lie. Someone
should go to jail,
health, lies and medicine. Okay. And the
health presentation by Dr. Joel Wallace.
I've got a picture of the book deadline
on the cover here. And so this followed
the presentation of the book. Okay. And
so um this what I say this is an
enormous it's like a college education
in two hours and nine minutes. Okay. On
about 25 different diseases. So I hope
everybody gets this. Uh we have about a
thousand of them left. As soon as we get
down to about 25, I'll order some more.
And uh it's one of those things where I
really haven't talked about it much over
the years, but this particular tool can
help you help your community, your
church family, your family, your
neighbors, your workmates. And just
remember, there are no genetic diseases.
If your doctor or their doctor said
problem they have is a genetic disease,
you need to seek out another
because the doctor doesn't know what's
going on. So, they're going to blame it
on you so they don't have to take the
blame for it for not knowing. This will
give you a college education in two
hours and eight minutes.
>> All right. Well, and that is a great
resource, folks, especially for those
that um want to see Dr. Wallik in his
prime when he was up on stage doing just
a fabulous job around the world. He
actually was traveling 300 days a year
giving presentations around the world.
This is a recording of one of those
presentations that is just absolutely
fantastic. You want to get your hands on
this program, you can give Wellness
Publications a call at what's the
number, doc? 800
>> 755-4656.
1 800755-4656.
And if somebody doesn't answer, that
means they're busy. So, just leave your
name and phone number. They'll call you
back. And um [clears throat]
this this is one of those things where
medical doctors do not get taught this
information in school.
That's what freaked me out. That's what
shocked me.
Anything that injures, infects,
disabled, and kills so many human
beings, medical doctors do not get
taught this in school in any way, shape,
or form. So, we had to take on
responsibility and make sure that
everybody on Earth, every living human
being got the information available to
them so they could save themselves, save
their families, save their communities,
and help contribute to saving humanity.
So, thank you for bringing it up,
Rebecca.
>> Oh, absolutely, Dr. Wallik. So, I'm
actually at a training right now that
has some doctors and and one of the
doctors, Dr. Wallik, he said when he got
wind of dead doctors don't lie. Somebody
had shared it with him and he listened
to that.
He was blown away. He said, "I didn't
learn any of this in medical school."
and now he's implementing your programs
into his practice and his patients are
getting better and better.
So, Dr. like we are really starting to
get into the medical family fields um
more and more and folks I if you are
part of
just just have a role in your
communities that helps to serve in the
field of medicine whether it's
alternative medicine whether it's
traditional medicine Chinese medicine
does not matter nutrition
will make your business thrive even
more. And the way that Dr. Wallik has
set this up, it has made it so that you
get a thank you check for helping
others.
I mean, what's not that we go for, you
know, any type of monetary gain because
we want to do good and help people, but
what can we use that thank you check to
do? help even more people.
So, get back with the person that shared
this program with you. If you're an
individual and you're you're in a
community that you want to help, get
back with the person that shared this
program with you. If you're a pastor and
you want to help your congregation
become healthier and healthier,
you're in the right place. Whether
you're watching us live or watching a
replay, the time is now.
to get started in helping others. Now,
this program is being livereamed on many
different platforms. If you're watching
on one of the live streams, make sure
that you follow our channel and share
this program with somebody you know and
love. Check out our others, but share at
least one with one person. If you go
through and you're listening and you
think of five people just with one
presentation, share it with all five,
right click, copy the link, and send it
to them in a text message. Just super
easy. That's all it takes to help change
a life. Now, Dr. Wallik,
I've had several questions come in.
you've done a case study and it's
happened more than once where you've
gotten positive results on a the
symptoms that are present with a
condition called Parkinson's
now
they say it's genetic doc is it genetic
>> no not at all not genetic it's very
simple nutritional deficiencies and of
course for over a hundred years. Um, the
United States has had 60,000 new cases
of Parkinson disease each year.
60,000 cases new cases each year for 100
years until last year. It went up 50% to
90,000
cases
per year. Okay? That's because doctors
made it worse by getting rid of the raw
materials necessary to make the mile and
the white matter of the brain and spinal
cord. Okay? They thought that
was bad, but it makes up 85% of your
brain.
So doctors are responsible. Doctors are
responsible. Doctors are responsible for
the rate of Parkinson's go up by 50% in
the last year because they cut out the
nutrition necessary for your brain and
spinal cord to make the myelin makes up
85% of your brain weight and your spinal
cord weight. And doctors think this raw
material that it takes to maintain your
brain and spinal cord was bad because
it's found in many tissues. You said,
"Well, that shouldn't be there." And so
they give you a pill to get you to
eliminate or
get rid of the substance that they think
is bad, but it makes up 85% of your
brain weight and 85% of your spinal cord
weight.
Oh, also it makes up about 85% of your
sex hormones. This is why all these
babies, little girls think they're boys,
little boys think they're girls. It's
because of all these crazy things that
doctors are doing, okay? Because they've
got it all wrong. They're going down the
wrong path and they're getting a
terrible result.
>> So, Dr. Wall, your approach,
the 90 essential nutrients,
>> that's correct.
60 of those are minerals.
>> That is correct.
>> And I don't think people understand that
in order for the body to be able to use
minerals, it takes multiple minerals
minerals working together. And for the
body to be able to use vitamins
properly,
it takes minerals to work together.
It's not just take one for this or one
for that.
It's feeding the whole body what it
needs.
>> That's correct.
>> So, Dr. Wallick, you were talking about,
you know, cholesterol, preventing
cholesterol. The the cholesterol that we
don't want is the stuff that's been
heated and fried, right?
>> Fried. Yeah, you can you can kind of
warm it up. Okay. But you want your your
meat medium rare. You don't want your
meat well done. You don't want your
chicken fried. You do not want your
chicken fried because if you eat fried
chicken, all that fat in the chicken
turns into something bad. But the the
fat in the chicken if it's just roasted
or boiled is okay. In fact, it's very
usable, very very useful.
Now, let's talk about some of the
symptoms of Parkinson's.
Okay. Um
there there's a shake. I think what the
shake is one that
>> trimmers
>> the trimmers
um a lot of people are having problems
with being able to have proper balance
in addition to the trimmers
>> and
>> what are some others?
>> Yeah. And the lifespan of somebody with
Parkinson disease after diagnosis is
somewhere between seven and 15 years.
>> Okay. They don't live very long after
they're diagnosed. It's a progressive
thing because they haven't changed their
dietary habits and they haven't changed
their supplement habits. So, it just
keeps getting worse and worse and worse.
The doctors try to treat the symptoms
[clears throat] because they get taught
in medical school it's a a genetic
thing. Well, everybody in my family's
got Parkinson's. Well, that's because
it's not genetic. It's because they're
all eating wrong things and cooking
improperly and so forth. They're all
using grandma's recipes and that's why
everybody's got it. It's not a genetic
thing. Parkinson's disease is a simple
nutritional deficiencies.
And we get the [clears throat] symptoms
to decrease in days and weeks after
getting off all the bad foods, getting
them on all the good foods and
supplements.
>> And then usually in less than three
months, that's why I always say, give me
90 days. Less than three months, most of
the people with Parkinson disease,
Parkinson disease goes away. Okay? And
they'll add 25 to 50 years to their
life. This is very simple. Um,
and again, this is where you need to get
a hold of the
this
>> the DVD set.
>> It's a DVD. It's a DVD. Okay. It's two
hours and 9 minutes.
And it's one of those things it'll blow
your mind how much we know and how much
we disease we can prevent, how much
disease we can reverse with nutrition.
But doctors want to use drugs and of
course people are happy to use drugs
because they have health insurance. Now
health insurance only came about at the
turn of the century. Before that there
was no health insurance and doctors
would milk the cow by charging you and
charging you and charging you and
charging you. So finally somebody said,
"Well, let's let's get some insurance
here and let the insurance company pay
for this stuff." Okay? And that's how
that happened. And it's one of those
things where
um
it's you know if you get in a car wreck
and you get multiple fractures and all
that kind of stuff it's a good thing
that you have health insurance. Okay.
And this is where the medical profession
really shine trauma whether it's the
military whether it's a highway accident
or somebody's in construction and falls
off the ladder. um kid falls off their
bike and breaks their leg or their
shoulder. All these things are easily
dealt with with both cast and all kinds
of surgeries, whatever is necessary. And
doctors really shine in that area. When
it comes to things like Parkinson
disease, they get it all wrong. And you
have to remember emergency room doctors
in America, emergency room doctors in
America live to be 55.7
to be 55 years and seven months. Now
>> I'm almost that doc. [laughter]
>> I'm not ready to go.
>> That's medical doctors. Okay. Now also
um medical doctors uh don't do well
when it comes to longevity. medical
doctors in America, the white medical
doctors live to be uh 75.7
something like that. And the black
medical doctors live to be 65.
And these people, the Hunzas that don't
have one single medical doctor in their
villages in the Himalayan mountains,
their average lifespan is 122. Is that a
genetic thing? No. But they're living in
the land flowing with milk and honey.
They're getting all these minerals
coming down out of the mountains. And of
course, it's in the streams and it looks
like milk. The the white powder because
the the rocks being ground up in the top
of the mountains by glaciers. That white
powder that resulted got into the
streams coming down the side of the
mountains. And from um you know, half a
mile away, a mile away, two miles away,
you see this white stream coming down
the side of the mountain. It looked like
milk. So that's and it's in the Old
Testament. It's in the Bible. 2,000
years ago, they talked about the the
white and milk, the land flowing with
milk and honey. So why was honey in
that? Because all these minerals coming
down the side of the mountains, okay,
irrigating the valleys and the fields,
all these flowers were there. So there's
more flowers, more bees, more honey. And
so the land flowing with milk and honey,
all was because of these minerals coming
down the side of the mountains. Now you
have to appreciate there's some
um of the um
I call it glacial milk. Okay, there's
some of this glacial milk that only have
three minerals because that's how many
minerals are in the rocks at top of
certain mountains. Some have 10
minerals, some have 25, some have 50 and
so on. You need at least 75 minerals.
They got to be the right ones, okay? to
get maximum benefit.
And all this is in the DVD, Dead Doctors
Don't Lie. It's in the book, Dead
Doctors Don't Lie. That's why it's a
bestseller. The metabolic syndrome uh
was in the Bible, the old Bible 2,000
years ago. Metabolic syndrome. It wasn't
called that, but it described the
abdominal obesity, type two diabetes,
and hypertension. Okay? And then it's
all in your head. Okay? there and it's
all in your head. There's over 50
different diseases you can get. More
than that, maybe closer to 60 different
disease you can get. You have
osteoporosis of the skull. My favorite
picture of course and I show this
probably it bores people but to me it's
my favorite picture
on page six of the book. It's all on
your head.
Okay. They take the top of the skull off
at autopsy sometimes. that all the time
but sometimes and they look down this in
the brain and the skull is a quarter
inch thick that's normal. All 12 pairs
of cranial nerves can get through the
tubes. The spinal cord can get through
the back of the skull. The bottom one is
a skull from somebody who had osteopro
to the skull. They took the top of the
skull off. They're looking down at the
brain. You can see the skull is an inch
and a half to two inches thick and it
shuts down those tunnels that those 12
pairs of craninal nerves go through and
also where the spinal cord goes through
the back of the skull and creates these
50 different diseases. And doctors want
to do surgery. They want to do
25 different drugs, okay, to deal with
these situations. And of course, there's
there's a chapter for each one of these
cranial nerves.
And it shows a picture here of the brain
shows the 12 pairs of cranial nerves
coming out and what parts of the body
are impacted when you have osteopro
skull squeezing those nerves. And then
on the other page there's 12 chapters
that go along. Okay, one chapter for
each of those cranial nerves. And then
for the spinal cord
um we have the um what it's very simple.
Okay. Oh, it's it's the information is
all in a CD. There we go. It's in a CD.
>> So, here's a set. You buy the book and
the CD at the same time. Get a nice
little project. It'll get rid of 50
different diseases that are caused by
osteoporosis of the skull. Don't let
doctors do surgery. Don't let them do
radiation. Don't let them put you on 18
different prescription drugs because
that's how they send their kid to
college.
So many of the conditions that are
associated with Parkinson's are because
of osteoporosis of the skull. That's
what you're saying, right, doc?
>> Well, there's a mixture there between
osteoposis of the skull, but the main
part of Parkinson's is a loss of the
myelin in the brain and spinal cord. The
loss of the myelin and the brain and
spinal cord. And then if you have
osteoporosis at the same time, you
really have a problem. He had
Parkinson's plus all
>> well and I and I know from from studying
with you Dr. Wallik some of the non
motor skill symptoms symptoms
like loss of smell.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Um extra salvation
salivation
>> um having pain or cramps in your muscles
and joints.
>> Yeah.
>> Blood pressure taste. You lose your
sense of taste. All that goes away when
you have osteoporosis of the skull.
>> And how about dizziness, Dr. Wallik?
>> Well, vision. When the skull squeezes
the optic nerve, you can lose your
vision gradually. Okay. You get
cataracts, you get cornea of corneial
problems. um
you get the um inside of the the eye
begins to slowly go away because it's
not getting any nutrition because the
skull is squeezing the um nerves going
from the brain into the the eye through
the through the optic nerve. Okay. The
eye also sends information back so you
can see, okay, and interpret things
where they're still or moving, okay,
through the optic nerve. And then the
optic nerve tells the eye what to do.
Turn right, turn left, go up, go down.
This is all controlled. But if you lose
the capacity to utilize all that because
your white man of your brain's going
away, doctors want to do surgery, they
want to do radiation, they want to do
all these drugs when really it's just a
nutritional deficiency.
>> Okay. And so how about a change in the
voice? A low voice, soft voice, would
that be
>> Oh, yeah.
>> because of nerves.
>> Absolutely. that deals with the cranial
nerves that deal with the throat and the
o vocal cords and the tongue and all
that kind of stuff. We'll talk about the
seventh and the eighth cranial nerves,
the trigeminal nerve, so forth all
contribute to these problems when
they're being squeezed or starved.
>> And and we talked about in the beginning
the trimmers or the the voluntary
movements of of the limbs, whether it's
your hands
get the diagnosis of Parkinson's
disease. Parkinson's was a guy many
years ago, okay, hundreds and hundreds
of years ago, who described these
tremors in certain people. Well, they
weren't getting the raw materials
to make the brain work properly and
maintain itself properly, which then
showed up with all these problems. Okay?
And
since it occurred in whole families,
well, it's a genetic thing.
because it's in the whole family. Well,
no, it's in the whole family because
everybody's eating grandma's recipe,
>> right?
>> And they didn't live in the land flowing
with no gun honey. Even if she had the
same recipe as her twin sister
who was say 100 miles away, feeding the
same food to their family 100 miles away
had no problems.
Why? Because they lived in land flowing
with milk and honey. And the one that
had all the problems was using the same
recipe, but they weren't getting the
nutrients because they didn't live in
the land flowing with milk and honey.
>> Well, in that land flowing with milk and
honey, I wanted I want to just kind of
um do a little bit of of clarification
on that.
Minerals do not occur in a solid blanket
around the world.
They're in veins like Dr. Wallik says
>> like gold and silver. I like chocolate
ripple ice cream. I like that analogy
better. But um the water that's flowing
is coming from areas and hopefully it's
coming from areas like the mountains
where there are more minerals that are
flowing downstream.
>> You have to appreciate that all
um glacial milk coming down the sides of
the mountains are not the same. Some
have three minerals because that's the
only minerals are in in that mountain.
And then some have five minerals, some
have 20 minerals, some have 50 minerals,
some have 75 minerals. And and so it
depends on how many minerals are in that
mountain will be how many minerals are
in the um glacial milk,
the land flowing with milk and honey.
>> And the greater the mineral deficiency,
the more symptoms you have, right, doc?
That's correct. And um you can have two
deficiencies, you can have 25
deficiencies, you can have 40
deficiencies. And this is why these
doctors, you know, the the night who are
working late shifts, okay, emergency
room doctors at night, they're living on
fast foods and coffee and that kind of
soft drinks and bubblies and all that
kind of stuff. They're doing everything
wrong. That's why their lifespan is only
55.7.
Well, Dr. Wallick, we're here to help
people know what to do, right? And we do
have some hands up. So, I want to make
sure that we do get to the hands that
are up and their questions. We have lots
of questions that are coming in through
the different chats. So, if you're on
YouTube, Rumble, any place that you can
or Facebook where you can leave a
comment, we do have pe parts of our team
watching for those comments so that we
can get an questions answered there
during the show. and also um here in the
Zoom room. So, as you're submitting
questions, it's coming to one of our
co-hosts. They're sharing that
information with me and we are here to
get answers to you. So, again,
if you were invited by somebody specific
and you want to get on a program that
Dr. Wallick is recommending one. Make
sure that you do have that chat open
because Marilyn, one of our co-hosts,
has this amazing gift of being able to
do transcription where she's typing what
Dr. Wallik is recommending into the chat
so that you can then take a screenshot
or a picture of it, take it to the
person that shared this program with you
and help they will help you get on the
right product based on what Dr. Wallik
has recommended for you. All right.
Again, if nobody has sent in or nobody
sent you here and you found us all on
your own, feel free to give us a call at
855-949-3377
and one of our certified holistic health
coaches will be able to help you. Again,
that's 855-949-3377.
And if we do not get to your question,
you can email them in
atquestwithdoc.com.
Now, this program is being sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com
where you will find articles and also
replays of past presentations on our
website. There is also an opportunity
sign up for our email list so that you
get a notification of when we are going
live which also includes information
about past programming so that you can
plug in and do searches through your
email when you're looking for specific
topics.
There is also a store there and as we're
going through Dr. Wallik is going to be
recommending good foods, bad foods list
and he rolls through that list pretty
fast, but you will find that whole list
on our website at dailywithdoc.com.
Just look right there in the menu and it
says Dr. Wallik's good foods bad foods
list. Dr. Wallik, you don't have to hold
your hand up. What's next?
>> Okay, I didn't want to rudely interrupt
you. I just wanted you to see that I I
wanted to add something here. We want to
make sure that people know that we have
a product. We we created and invented a
product to rebuild the myelin in the
brain and spinal cord because I didn't
mention that earlier I don't think.
Okay, that's the I20 I26. I26 and we
have chewables. We have capsules. We
have powder. I like the chewables. I
take the French vanilla tubils. They
also come in what? Um
>> banana coconut.
>> Banana coconut. That's one of our
favorites. People buy that one for their
kids and then their mamas and dads.
Okay. um, banana, coconut, but we also
have the the capsules. We also have the
powder you can stir in. It comes in a
canister, so you can stir that into your
drinks. And the um,
the the I26
gives
the skull all the raw materials it needs
to make.
>> That's the coating on the brain that
it's the raw materials for, right?
>> That's right. It it gives the brain what
it needs to make the myelin, the white
matter in the brain and spinal cord.
Plus, it helps you make all your sex
hormones. That's two good things. One at
the top, one at the bottom. Right.
[laughter]
>> There you go. There you go. So, do
>> this is so important. The I26. I take
three of those tubils twice a day. Okay.
And it's one of those things where uh
you have to be really really really
careful not to get so busy you forget to
take them because you don't want to wind
up with Parkinson disease and you get
scared and you run to the doctor and
they give you all these drugs and then
couple of years later you're dead.
>> Right. So Dr. Wallick we have somebody
that has Parkinson's. We wanted to give
them a protocol. If that person is 150
pounds, what would be your full ultimate
recommendation for them as far as
nutrition goes
to help their bodies be able to to work
to become healthier?
>> Okay. Well, u you have both males and
females. And so, everybody, both males
and females need the 90 essential
nutrients to help the brain and heart
pack. full dose, half a dose of
breakfast, half a dose of dinner time
for each 100 pounds for both males and
females. Um they also need the um
zerapim for girls and zerotess for boys
because they're also made out of the
same raw materials that are necessary
for the white matter of your brain. So
if you have one going bad at the bottom,
it's also going bad at the top. And so,
okay. And so, you really want to pay
attention. And so, 150 pounds, they need
in addition to everything we've just
said, they also need, remember, zero
test for guys and zero fem for girls.
Uh, I I take two or three of those
tablets twice a day. I'm 85 years old
and want to keep going.
So
the at 150 pounds, we also want take
when it comes to the
um uh I26 again we have the flip chart.
Okay, page 26, 27, 28
and uh 29, 30. Those are all really good
ones. Okay, and it helps you understand
what you're doing. But you want to take
the I26. Take at least
two or three of those twice a day. Okay?
15 150 pounds, right? 157 pounds, 158
pounds, whatever it is.
>> 150
>> 150. Okay? They need to be taking um two
or three doses. If they already have
Parkinson's disease, they need to be
taking two or three doses of the I26 a
day. In addition to all the other
supplements we talked about, they need
to be eating three eggs twice a day,
softboiled in butter, not margarine.
They can be poached, okay? But they need
to be if they're going to soft boil
them, soft scramble them in butter, not
margarine. Um,
and so it's one of those things where
you can we see people who had Parkinson
disease for 10, 15, 20 years and in four
or five days they're seeing benefit. In
a couple weeks, they're seeing a lot of
benefit. In a month, it's all gone. Two
months it's all gone. And on this page
27 of the slip chart, okay, uh, 94 life
crusade to save humanity in the world.
On page 27, it has a story of Meline O.
The last name begins with an O. We just
put O period because if we put her whole
last name, she'd have a thousand people
on her front lawn every day.
And basically, she was going downhill
very rapidly over a period of 9, 10, 11
years. She going to a neurologist and
very famous medical school, okay, on the
East Coast. And getting worse, worse,
worse. and they
told you know her family that the end
was about here. Well, one of her
relatives who are member of Young Jewy
um got a hold of us. Okay. And um the
what we you know told them was to make
sure she gets all these things
and they did and they gave her you know
couple of doses a day the I26 and all
the 90 essential nutrients and all this
that and the other and in three months
she was perfectly normal at age I think
11 years.
So
>> that that is Yeah, I remember that
story. That is fantastic. Do I look like
Becca?
>> Say again.
>> I said, "Do I look like Becca?" Cuz I
just switched the screen. Becca's
internet is having a little difficulty.
So, I'm going to help us out here. And
um So, what do you think about Ultimate
Daily Classic? Can we add Ultimate Daily
Classic to that protocol as well?
>> Oh, absolutely. Um, Ultimate Daily
Classic, of course,
um, it's one of those things where, um,
what should I say?
You want to make sure that all all the,
um, the brain, the heart, the kidneys,
uh, the sex tissue, the liver, uh, lungs
get everything they need from every
direction.
Drugs will relieve symptoms.
And for thousands of years, doctors and
herbalists have been using drugs and
herbs and things like that to reduce
symptoms. They didn't know the causes of
diseases 50 years ago, 100 years ago,
500 years ago, a thousand years ago. But
they were they were knew that these
herbs would reduce the symptoms. They
knew that these groundup rocks over here
look like this would reduce symptoms.
And so that's how medicine got started
was reducing
symptoms. They did 400 years ago with
the colloidal silver. Get rid of all
kinds of terrible pandemics,
okay? And epidemics with colloidal
silver. And so this is why we have
colloidal silver. I take two droppers
full under my tongue, one on one side,
one on the other side. under my tongue.
10 minutes before breakfast, 10 minutes
for lunch, and 10 minutes before dinner
time, 10 minutes for bed. I've been
doing that for over 40 years. And so
that's why I can go to a meeting with a
hundred or 500 or thousand people and
they're all coughing and hacking. And I
don't come down with any of these
diseases because I'm taking the
colloidal silver to kill or colloidal
silver kills all viruses, all bacteria,
all fungus, all yeast. Penicellin only
kills two bacteria, nothing else.
>> So which one you want? You want
something that kills all bugs or just
two bugs?
>> I want the one you suggest, Doc.
[laughter]
So, we have some questions. We're going
to start with Ruth Ellen. Hopefully, she
can go rapid fire on some of the
questions that came in today. Ruth
Ellen, what questions are you bringing
to Daily with Doc?
>> Well, I've been getting a lot of
questions in the chat. So, um, let me
start at the beginning here.
Um, I have Fly Boy
44. He says, "Dr. Wallik, do you had
have advice on
how to help with neuropathy?"
And I don't have any um information
regarding weight, sex, or any of that.
>> Okay. Well, neuropathy can be caused by
many things. Anything that puts pressure
on a nerve. Okay. Can cause weird
symptoms or cause everything to go dead
by squeezing a nerve. This is called
neuropathy. Okay. And so again, this is
where you have to get rid of all the bad
stuff. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no glutens, no wheat, no
buckwheat, no sugar, no carbonated
drinks. The diamonds got to go. And then
you need to take the 90 essential
nutrients. 60 minerals, 16 vitamins, 12
minerals, three fatty acids. And it's we
have the healthy brain and heart pack.
It started out as a healthy start pack
and then we made it into the healthy
bone and joint pack for Theo Ratliff and
got him back in basketball. He made over
$130 million in nine years on contracts
after we fixed him after he was kicked
out of basketball because of his joints
and his hips and his knees and so forth.
Made $130 million in nine years. That's
pretty good for a comeback.
>> Yes, it is. Yes, it is. It is. So,
>> it's one of those things where um this
is what you got to do. You got to get
rid of all the bad stuff. And then don't
forget
elder and heart pack. Don't forget the
um
which you want to be sure of using the
colloidal silver in case there's an
infection in there. You want to make
sure you're using the
um everything that has to do with
myelin, the white matter, the brain. And
we're talk, you know, we're talking
about the the um
what what' you do for milein?
>> I26.
>> What?
>> I 26.
>> I There you go. You get an A+ I26.
[laughter]
>> Again, it comes in chewables. It comes
in um capsules. It comes in powder. And
just be sure that you're eating properly
[clears throat] and taking all your 90
essential nutrients.
I've been doing this for 75 years and um
you know again I'm using the Chinese
method of aging. I'm 85. The Chinese
give you credit for your nine months of
pregnancy.
So when you're born you're already nine
months old in China,
>> right?
>> And when you when you ask somebody how
old are you? Well, I was born and they
go by their birth date. They forget it
took nine months to get there. Okay? And
if you're not taking all your nutrients,
that's going to be a terrible, terrible
event when you get born and you have all
these problems,
>> right?
>> Think your girls, your little girls,
think your boys, uh, you have all kinds
of birth effects, physical and
biochemical birth effects because mama
wasn't eating all the proper things and
supplementing properly during pregnancy,
right?
>> It's all preventable.
Okay. And this is I learned this as a
kid on the farm. I said, "Well, why are
we giving them all this stuff and we're
not getting all this stuff
>> and
it was very obvious what was going on
there."
>> Okay. So, my next question is from Don
Mahaney and he would like to know what
is wrong with peanuts.
>> I'm sorry. What is wrong with what?
>> Peanuts. Why? Why do you say they're on
the bad food list?
>> Okay. What's wrong with peanuts? Yes.
>> All right. We have to appreciate that I
did a 10-year study when I was going
through school in Missouri, I did a
10-year study with Washington [snorts]
University pathology study, autopsies on
animals and people. And I was learning
that in every zoo in the world,
every zoo in the world, the bears were
getting liver cancer, right? Why were it
didn't matter? Black bear, white bears,
sun bears, grizzly bears, polar bears,
all the bears are getting liver cancer.
What's going on here? I asked people and
they said, "Well, we don't know. They
just they're susceptible to it." Oh,
okay. Well, well, it turns out that they
were selling peanuts. All these zoos
were selling peanuts at the front gate
to make money so they could run their
operation. And people are throwing the
peanuts to the bears. The bears learn to
stand up and wave their arms and and the
people would rush there and make the
bears stand up and throw the peanuts to
them. and in a couple years time they
would die of liver cancer. Well, it
turns out that peanuts grow in the
ground and they're contaminated by a
fungus that produces a substance that
causes liver cancer.
And so, why do you think that people who
are beer drinkers every Friday and
Saturday night in the bars, why do you
think they get liver cancer? Is it
genetic?
>> They're eating peanuts that are by the
bar. They're the the bar is giving them
the peanuts and they're getting liver
cancer also. That's why people get liver
cancer who are beer drinkers in the bars
and I'm the guy that figured all that
out.
>> Yes, you are.
>> Okay.
>> I'm grateful for you. Thank you.
>> All right. So, the next question.
>> Yes. Thank you so much. You did a great
job. That was perfect. Um, so Sally Cobb
asks, "My 40-year-old son is losing
hearing in his right ear only. His left
ear is fine. He had an MRI, but nothing
showed up. What are your thoughts?"
>> And I don't have any weight or anything
like that. So, we'll go by 100 pounds.
>> How old is he?
>> 40 years old.
>> You know how much he weighs?
>> No, sir.
>> Okay. So let's say an average guy
anywhere from 170 to 200 pounds kind of
thing.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So um
and so do we know of anything else about
this guy?
>> No, that's all I was given.
>> Okay. So um
>> Oh, she says 170 pounds. Thank you,
Sally.
>> Okay, we came close. 170 pounds.
>> Yes, you did.
Okay. Now remember hearing
okay goes along with what cranial nerves
number seven and eight
okay they get squeezed it could be on
one side not the other side doesn't have
to be both sides at the same time. Okay
to me he's probably got osteoporosis of
the skull and he should have a look at
the skull and see what the measurements
are. Is the skull a quarter of an inch
thick like normal or is it a/ inch
thick? Is it two inches thick? Is it
inch and a half thick? Okay. Because
when you start get losing hearing,
especially in one ear, that means that
that nerve, okay, is being squeezed as
it passes from the brain through the
skull to the outside.
Okay? And so this is something that we
need to know. have somebody else look at
those X-rays if he has X-rays and see if
there is a little bit. I don't care if
it's just a couple of millimeters. Okay.
>> Be pushing on a nerve.
>> Okay. I'll have them um review the MRI.
>> Yeah. But they need to in the meantime
they can at
>> 70 pounds. Yeah. Two Heather and heart
packs. They were all the bad stuff. Two
Heather Brain and hard packs a full dose
twice a day. They need the Ultimate
Daily um classic. Okay, Ultimate Daily
Classic twice a day. I like the rebound
for for energy drinks. Okay, has all
kinds of great nutrients in it. And it
wouldn't hurt to use the CM cream
on the neck, behind the skull, behind
the ears, on the cheek, between the eye
and the ear. Okay.
>> Okay. take a Q-tip, put a little CM
cream down in the ear with a Q-tip and
see if that won't help. But this is the
odds are it's approaches to the skull
squeezing those cranial nerves.
>> Okay. All right. Thank you so much. And
my next question was from Cheryl, but
and Cheryl has her hand up, so we're
going to go to Cheryl. So Cheryl, if you
could unmute.
>> Hi.
Cheryl, can you unmute?
>> All right. Well, while Cheryl's figuring
that out, we could go to AJ. Well, doc,
as you were talking about osteoporosis
of the skull, uh, we had a question from
uh, excuse me, we had a question from
Bill who says, "Well, what do I say to
people when I tell them about
osteoporosis of the skull?" And they say
to me, "Well, osteoporosis is a
reduction of bone. So, how does it
squeeze a nerve?"
>> Okay. Yes, it's a reduction of bone. So,
what takes the place of the bone? It's
connective tissue. And this is why I
came up with this picture just to answer
that question. This book, everybody who
sees people live need or even talk to on
the phone needs to get a couple of
copies of this book. It's all in your
head and go to page six and you'll see
the top skull is a normal skull. It's a
quarter inch thick. The bottom skull is
an inch and a half to two inches thick.
That's not bone.
That's scar tissue.
The scar tissue is filling up and
closing all 12 pairs of tunnels that the
12 pairs of cranial nerves go through.
It's closing the spinal cord opening in
the back of the skull where the spinal
cord is coming through and putting
pressure on all those nerves and that's
why they have all these symptoms. Okay,
you go to page seven, the next page,
it shows a picture of the brain and
where these 12 pairs of cranial nerves
go, what tissues they go to. And then on
the next page, it shows there's 12
pairs, excuse me, there's 12 chapters.
There's one chapter for each cranial
nerve and tells you what diseases, what
symptoms you're going to get when that
nerve gets squeezed. Everybody who is
seeing live patients needs to have at
least one of these books. One in your
car, one in your house, one in your
workplace, okay? Or put in your
briefcase, put one in your briefcase.
Everybody in your family needs to have
one of these books. You'll add many
healthy years to their life and the claw
their life will go way up because when
you have something going on with the 12
pairs of cranial nerves,
you're talking about 50 different
diseases here.
Doc, we have smart people who follow you
and watch the show. I just want can we
can we just get a little more specific
like you've done in the past? We we
talked about demineralization
and then filling up with this connective
scar tissue. is is that kind of
kind of an example I kind of use
sometimes is a piece of steel is very
strong and it's minerals but if you use
wood to be the same strength of that
steel that wood would be a lot thicker.
Is that kind of a good analogy of what
you're going there with is
to have the same strength that wood
would have to be a lot more thick. Okay.
Yeah. Okay. And so you have to
appreciate that when you have the skull,
the skull isn't made for walking on. The
skull is made to cover the brain from
minor impact and rain and all that kind
of stuff. Okay? It's not meant to be
whacked in the head with a baseball bat.
Okay? But also it requires nutrients to
to maintain its strength and structure
and to do its job which is to protect
protect the brain and the cranial nerves
the 12 pairs of cranial nerves and the
spinal cord. Okay? And people talk about
the brain a lot but they never talk
about the 12 pairs of cranial nerve. I'm
the first guy to talk about the 12 pairs
of cranial nerves to nutritional groups.
They never heard of such a thing. They
just knew there's the brain and the
spinal cord. And so it's one of those
things where this flip chart was a
necess necessity,
this flip chart. And of course there's a
whole guy like three four pages um on
Parkinson's disease.
And we we have uh all of these
CDs and books and things that deal with
the with um Parkinson's disease. We can
get rid of Parkinson. We can prevent
Parkinson disease. It's not a genetic
thing. Even though it occurs in your
entire family because everybody's eating
grandma's recipes, not getting all the
nutrients they need to maintain healthy
tissues in the brain and and spinal cord
and so forth and also the bones and
skull and vertebrae and so on. Uh this
is not complex but it is what should I
say very sensitive. [clears throat]
Just like your car. If you just put
water in your gasoline tank, it'll show
full on your gauge.
It'll show full on your gauge.
>> But how far are you gonna go?
>> Not very far.
>> Yeah, I can't get started. It says I'm
full of gasoline there, but I can't get
started. Well, somebody put water in
your tank instead of gasoline. That's
why you can't move. Okay. Well, the same
thing is true with your brain, your 12
pairs of cranial nerves, your spinal
cord. You need all the nutrients to make
sure your brain is has the the access to
the outside world. Okay? Because it
wants information from the outside world
to come in through those nerves into the
brain. And then the brain wants to be
able to send signals out from the brain
through the skull to the outside world
to to help the outside world do. Okay.
So, uh again, having done over 30,000
autopsies and looking at the skulls of
each one of them, I learned a lot. Um,
most doctors don't look at the skulls,
okay? Because they have x-rays of the
bra, you know, the skull and all that
kind of stuff. So, they don't want to
whack open a brain and all that kind of
thing.
And so, I'm doing all this these um
scientific studies and writing articles
and all this kind of stuff. And people
are freaking out. Well, w what do you
know about all that? Well, I'm up to my
eyeballs here in information and I can't
find it anywhere else. So, I'm going to
put it into books and CDs and DVDs. And
I did. And we started a whole new
science with epigenetics.
Epigenetics takes a replacement. It's a
replacement for genetics. There are no
genetically trim um cause diseases.
Genetics give you hair color, eye color,
skin color, and gender. That's it.
That's all the genetics do. Genetics do
nothing else.
>> Yes. Dr. Wall. And I uh we can't get
Cheryl to ask her question, but Ruth
Ellen, are you going to bring that in,
please? Because we're running we're
running short on time.
>> Cheryl did not put Oh, she did not put
her question in the chat. She wanted to
ask it herself. And I
>> Cheryl, if you can uh try to unmute
again.
>> All right.
>> Oh, she'll be there. Well, listen.
Cheryl's not there. She can uh
>> there. She just It's not working for her
to unmute,
>> right? Email us at questions at
dailywithdoc.com and we'll try and help
her out that way. Uh thank you everybody
for joining us. Doc, you have any
closing words for the folks? Well, the
holidays are coming up and people want
to give gifts of love
uh to their families and friends and
church mates and workmates and
neighbors. Guess what? Get a hold of
these books. Get it's all in your head.
Get a hold uh of the the book
Epigenetics. Get a hold of the book
Metabolic Syndrome. Uh get a hold of the
book Dead Doctors Don't Lie. And if you
really really want to sit down with
somebody and watch the story because
it's all on the back cover, okay, of
this um DVD,
okay, it goes along with the book, okay?
Goes along with the book, Dead Doctors
Don't Lie. So, everybody needs to get a
hold of this. We have 100 copies sitting
at at Wellness Publications. That's uh
uh let's see here.
call at 800755-4656.
>> 1800755-4656.
Okay? And get this, get the book. And
you can add 25 to 50 years to people's
lives with this information. You can add
25 to 50 years with this information.
Doctors cannot do that with drugs.
>> That's right, doc. That's why we are
here supporting every move you make. And
uh we are we are committed because all
of us have benefited by your research
and by your formulations and we thank
you very much. And Ruth Ellen,
>> we are family. Thank you all. We are
family. We are family. We are family.
Can't thank you enough for being here.
You're there 247,
okay? And you've been with me some of
you many, many years and some of you
many years to come. Thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Dr. Wallik. And thank
you, AJ. You can carry on and close us
out.
>> All right, everybody. So, uh just uh a
little housekeeping. If you know, you
don't have to figure out this health
stuff by yourself.
If you know, you don't need to go to a
website and say, you know, what products
do I need to get? If you you can have
help figuring out what supplements would
be best for you and for your budget,
reach out and speak to a certified
holistic health coach at 8559493377
or email questions at dailywithdoc.com.
Just want to thank the team uh who who
are here on the screen with us. Rutellan
Sanchez is uh the production manager and
Albert and uh Jeffrey behind him are
here all the way from South Africa
making sure that this is a safe space
for all of us to participate with and we
have fingers on the bottom of the screen
typing in everything into the chat so
that we are able to recap what Dr.
Wallak has said and people can uh know
what the protocols are. But again, if
you miss something, you can uh reach out
to us at questions at dailywithdoc.com
or 8559493377.
Tonight will be a pharmacist Ben's bite
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern time. So, if you
can tune in, uh we'd we'd love to have
you tune in and
um we thank uh Becca Dukes who is on
vacation or excuse me on a work trip so
her internet signal kind of faded out
and that's what happens when you do
these work trips on all these tropical
places uh that have hurricanes coming.
So, um, thanks everyone for joining us
today on Daily with Doc. Dr. Wallak,
you're the man. Thank you very much.
>> Thank you, AJ. Thank you, everybody. God
bless each and every one of you.
>> Thank you, everybody, for joining us.
>> God bless you.
>> Thank you, Doc. Bye for now.
>> Bye-bye.
>> [music]
>> Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. The
content is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any diseases,
[music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual sharing
their [music] testimony. Results vary
and may not be typical. We do not make
any claims regarding [music] health or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to have the founding father of
the science of epigenetics guiding us
with the best options to obtain or
maintain optimal health, Dr. Joel
Wallik.
Welcome to Daily with Doc and Becca.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. The
content is not intended to diagnose,
treat, cure, or prevent any diseases,
[music]
nor is it intended to take the place of
your primary care physician.
Testimonials [music]
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual sharing their testimony.
Results vary and may not be typical. We
do not make any claims regarding health
or income. As an [music] empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We are honored to have the
founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health. Dr. Joel Wallik